HAVE A QUORUM BUT WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND BEGIN A SUBCOMMITTEE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
COLLEAGUES -- I APPRECIATE YOUR
EXTEND IN THE COURTESY TO LET ME
GO FIRST.
I AND CERTAINLY THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT SB.
FOUR FIFTY ONE THIS MEASURE
WOULD CREATE AN INCENTIVE FOR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THROUGH THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A TAX CREDIT
FOR THE PRESERVATION AND
REHABILITATION OF HISTORIC
BUILDINGS IN CALIFORNIA.
IF ENACTED CALIFORNIA WOULD JOIN
THIRTY FIVE OTHER STATES WITH
STATE HISORIC TAX CREDIT
PROGRAMS.
THE BENEFITS OF SUCH A CREDIT
ARE WELL DOCUMENTED.
I WILL HIGHLIGHT JUST A FEW
HOUSING PROJECTS THAT RECEIVE
THE FEDERAL VERSION OF THE TAX
CREDIT.
BECAUSE THESE ARE THE TYPES OF
PROJECTS -- WOULD.
FURTHER BENEFIT FROM A STATE
CREDIT. ONE SUCH EXAMPLE IS IN
MY DISTRICT THE HISTORIC SAN
DIEGO ATHLETIC CLUB BUILDING WAS
TURNED INTO CONNECTIONS HOUSING.
WHICH NOW PROVIDES TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE APARTMENTS WITH
SUPPORT OF SERVICES TO THE
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS POPULATION.
IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOOSE
DISTRICT THE SAN FRANCISCO YMCA
BUILDING WAS RESTORED TO CONVERT
FORMER HOTEL ROOMS IN TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO SUPPORT
OF HOUSING UNITS FOR CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS.
THE FACILITY STILL HOUSES A
COMMUNITY JAM AN AUDITORIUM
WHILE ALSO PROVIDING HEALTH IN
SUPPORT OF SERVICES TO THE
CITY'S HOMELESS POPULATION.
BY ENABLING CALIFORNIANS TO
LEVERAGE THE FEDERAL
REHABILITATION TAX CREDITS IT'S
OUR HOPE THAT THIS MEASURE WOULD
PROVIDE THE EXTRA INCENTIVE
NECESSARY TO STIMULATE PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE INVESTMENTS.
WHILE ALSO BUILDING CIVIC PRIDE
AS WE CELEBRATE OUR HERITAGE AND
PRESERVE CALIFORNIA'S PASSED.
I HAVE A TWO WITNESSES MADAM
CHAIR WITH ME TODAY TO OFFER
THEIR EXPERTISE AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
AND I WILL LET THEM INTRODUCED
WITH YOUR PERMISSION LET THEM
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES AND THEIR
TITLES OF COURSE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
ATKINS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CINDY HEIGHTS MAN I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA PRESERVATION
FOUNDATION IN SAN FRANCISCO.
I'M HERE TO SEEK YOUR SUPPORT OF
SB.
FOUR FIFTY ONE HISTORIC TAX
CREDIT STIMULATE PRIVATE
INVESTMENT TO EXTEND THE
ECONOMIC LIFE OF OLDER BUILDINGS
A REVITALIZED COMMUNITIES.
THIS BILL IS AN INVESTMENT
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITIES LARGE
AND SMALL NEWS WORTHY OF YOUR
SUPPORT.
IN CALIFORNIA SOME OF OUR MOST
BELOVED LANDMARKS ARE HERE TODAY
BECAUSE THE FEDERAL TAX CREDITS.
THE FERRY BUILDING SAN FRANCISCO
ORPHEUM THEATRE IN LOS ANGELES
CENTRAL YMCA SAN FRANCISCO THE
FOREMAN INGLEWOOD.
LIBERTY STATION SAN DIEGO.
AMONG THE NUMEROUS BENEFITS
DERIVED FROM THE FEDERAL AND
STATE TO START TAX CREDITS IS
THE INCENTIVE TO CREATE HOUSING
AND HISTORIC BUILDINGS.
PLACES WITH CHARACTER AND
COMMUNITY.
NATIONWIDE HISTORIC TAX PROJECTS
HAVE REHABILITATED OVER A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND UNITS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SINCE.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX IN
CALIFORNIA SINCE 2000738% OF ALL
FEDERAL HISTORIC TAX CREDIT
PROJECTS CREATED NEW HOUSING.
AND THE OF THAT AMOUNT OVER HALF
WERE AFFORDABLE. THIRTY FIVE
OTHER STATES HAVE PROVEN THAT
THERE'S A POSITIVE RETURN ON THE
STATE'S INVESTMENT THROUGH STATE
HISTORIC TAX CREDITS.
TODAY WE SECURE SUPPORT INVEST
BEFORE.
FIFTY ONE THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ON TONY
GONZALEZ -- I REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA PRESERVATION
FOUNDATION BUT TODAY.
I'M HERE TO SHARE WITH YOU THE
STRONG SUPPORT OF AS BEFORE
FIFTY ONE BY THE CO SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL.
THE AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF
ARCHITECTS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
BRIEF PAUSE WE HAVE A QUORUM IS
HIGHLY WE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
BURKE HERE [inaudible]
ROBERT [inaudible]
CHU GRAY.
MAYES MELENDEZ MULLIN
[inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
WORK HERE RIVAS.
KING THERE.
OF COURSE.
WE HAVE A QUORUM ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
REVENUE CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PLAY JOHNSON HERE ABOUT THE
STATE'S HAS A FEW ON A MOCK HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
START QUIRK -- SO THERE'S YOU
HAVE PUT SOMETHING IN THERE THAT
I WANTED TO UNDERSTAND -- AND
THAT IS THAT YOU ALLOW US AN
OWNER OCCUPIED BUILDING TO
QUALIFY.
AND MY CONCERN ABOUT THAT IS THE
PEOPLE I KNOW WHO HAVE -- OWNER
OCCUPIED BUILDINGS THEY WERE
GONNA FIX THEM ANYWAY SO IT
WOULD SEEM AS IF THIS IS GIVING
MONEY FOR IT'S WHAT WE CALL THE
FREE RIDER PROBLEM.
IS THERE A PARTICULAR REASON YOU
DECIDE TO INCLUDE THAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK I'M SO
GLAD YOU ASKED THAT QUESTION ALL
RIGHT I'M YOU KNOW I I HAVE
FOLLOWED COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
FOR A NUMBER OF DECADES I SERVED
ON THE CITY COUNCIL WAS A STAFF
MEMBER.
I'M QUITE FAMILIAR WITH --
HISTORIC HOMES IN COMMUNITIES
WHERE -- PEOPLE WERE BASICALLY
ABLE TO BUY THOSE HOMES IN THE
SEVENTIES EIGHTIES NINETIES NOW
THE FINANCIAL SITUATION IN OUR
STATE IS MUCH DIFFERENT IN TERMS
OF THE ABILITY TO OWN HOMES.
THERE ARE MANY MIDDLE INCOME LOW
TO MIDDLE INCOME FOLKS WHO
ACTUALLY WERE ABLE TO BUY A HOME
IN THE EARLY YEARS.
THOSE HOMES ARE BE INTEGRATED
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY SO I TRIED TO PUT
BUMPERS ARE PARAMETERS AROUND
THE ABILITY. FOR INDIVIDUALS TO
ACCESS THESE RESOURCES -- FOR
INDIVIDUAL HOMES BUT I WANTED
THEM STILL TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
I CAN SEND YOU A PICTURE
ALTHOUGH I DON'T WANT -- TO
DON'T WORRY I WILL DO IT
PERSONALLY BUT I DON'T WANT TO
EMBARRASS THE HOMEOWNER IN A
HISTORIC NEIGHBORHOOD NEAR MY
HOUSE.
WHERE THIS INCREDIBLE HOME AND I
HAPPEN TO KNOW -- THE INDIVIDUAL
IS INCOME STRAPPED BUT THEY
DIDN'T -- SELL THEIR HOME.
AND SO I WANT TO BE PRESERVING
THESE ARE SPANISH COLONIAL
CRAFTSMEN EVERYTHING THAT IS
CALIFORNIA HISTORIC.
UP FOR THOSE WHO NEEDED AND IF
THERE'S RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
THIS COMMITTEE OR ANY WOULD HAVE
UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT IS MY
INTENT -- AS OPPOSED TO TRYING
TO GIVE OUR HOMEOWNERS WHO YOU
MIGHT THINK HAVE THE ABILITY TO
TO DO THIS WORK AND I THINK WE
LIMITED THE AMOUNT OF MONEY WE
WANT TO BE VERY CAREFUL AND
ASSESS IT.
GOING FORWARD BUT THAT WAS MY
RATIONALE.
RIGHT AND THEN -- SINCE HOUSING
IS OUR BIG PROBLEM SHOULD
HOUSING PROJECTS HAVE PRIORITY
OVER OTHER PROJECTS WHEN YOU'VE
LIMITED TO FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS --
POSSIBLY I MEAN I'M OPEN TO
DISCUSSION BUT MY WITNESS HERE
MENTIONED FOR EXAMPLE THE FERRY
BUILDING IN SAN FRANCISCO AND I
WOULD SAY IF YOU LOOK AT THAT
BUILDING.
ON THE INTENT THERE WAS ALSO TO
DRIVE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
IF YOU ARE ABLE TO GO IN YOU
WILL SEE THAT MOST OF THE
BUSINESSES THAT OCCUPY THE FERRY
BUILDING.
OUR LOCAL SMALL BUSINESSES.
AND SO I THINK IT DEPENDS ON THE
ON THE CERTAINLY THE PROJECT
CLEARLY I ALWAYS BELIEVE HOUSING.
I WHEN YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THESE
ARE OLD WAREHOUSES THAT HAVE
BEEN CONVERTED THE WHY.
OF THE BUILDING I REFERENCED IN
SAN DIEGO I AM OPEN TO THAT
CONVERSATION AS WELL BUT I THINK
THE FLEXIBILITY IN TERMS OF IT
ALSO BE AN ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITY -- WAS THE INTENT
YEAH.
ALL RIGHT WELL THERE'S THERE'S
STILL IS THE QUESTION OF FREE
RIDERS.
THINGS THAT WOULD HAVE HAPPENED
ANYWAY BUT I'LL LEAVE IT UP TO
THE CHAIR.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS -- FOR MYSELF THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING UP THE FORUM
THREE OF ITS ABILITY
REHABILITATION OF THE FORM HAS
BEEN A HUGE ECONOMIC DRIVER
FRANK AWAY THEN IT HAS LAUNCHED
US INTO STADIUMS AND OTHER
AMAZING OPPORTUNITIES SO THANK
YOU FOR MENTIONING THAT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I I THINK THAT'S MORE THAN
ENOUGH AYE YOU UNDERSTAND MY
INTENT I HAVE CERTAINLY BROUGHT
THIS BILL FORWARD BEFORE I WOULD
LOVE TO HAVE THIS AS A
LEVERAGING OPPORTUNITY FOR
DEVELOPMENTS WHETHER IT BE --
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING OUR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES I IT WITH A LOSS
OF REDEVELOPMENT ARE WE HAD
THOSE RESOURCES TO SPUR SOME OF
THE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT I THINK
THIS IS AN ADDITIONAL TOOL ALONG
WITH THE FEDERAL TOOL.
I TO ACCOMPLISH A MULTITUDE OF
THINGS I WOULD AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME NOT NOW I KNOW
I HOPE THAT THIS COMMITTEE AND
THE CHAIR.
LOOKS AT THIS BILL FAVORABLY.
THANK YOU AND IT IS FOR
TESTIMONY ONLY BUT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION THANKS.
MOVING TO THE FILE ITEM TO SB
ONE NINETY SIX SENATOR BELL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- THIS IS SB ONE NIGHT
TO SIX WHICH IS THE COMMUNITY
LAND TRUST PROJECT DEVELOPMENT
BILL -- I WANT TO THANK THE
STAFF -- FOR WORKING WITH US AND
WE WILL AMEND THE BILL AS PER
YOUR COMMITTEES POLICY AND STAFF
RECOMMENDATION.
THE BILL WILL CREATE A MORE
PERMANENT AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
LOW AND MODERATE INCOME FAMILIES.
BY PROVIDING PROPERTY TAX RELIEF
FOR COMMUNITY LAND TRUST --
THERE'S NO SILVER BULLET.
INVOLVING THE HOUSING CRISIS BUT
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST OR PART OF
THE SOLUTION.
THESE ARE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT PROVIDE PERMANENTLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
NOW THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST.
WITH THE PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION
FROM THE POINT OF PROPERTY
ACQUISITION. TO THE POINT OF
SALE FOR AFFORDABLE HOMES.
THIS WILL BRING THE TREATMENT OF
COMMUNITY LAND TRUSTS.
IN LINE WITH OTHER COMMUNITY
BASED NONPROFITS THAT BENEFITED
FROM AN EXISTING WELFARE
EXEMPTION.
AND WE HAVE WITNESSES IN FAVOR
OF TURN OVER THEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IN A SENSE.
FOR YOUR WORK THANK YOU.
MARKET SERIOUS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE RANKING LAND
TRUST AND PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE LAND TRUST
NETWORK THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
JUST WANTED REPRESENT THAT WE
ARE HERE IN SUPPORT AT CENTRE
BELL HAS CAP SLATED VERY NICELY
OUR POSITION WE DO PROVIDE
PERMANENT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BOTH OWNERSHIP AND RENTAL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE THINK.
THAT THAT IS AN IMPORTANT
BENEFIT FOR THE STATE.
AND IT DOES HELP TO ADDRESS THE
HOUSING ISSUES ARE A ADDRESSING
THE STATE AT THIS POINT IN TIME
SO WE ARE BASICALLY HERE.
TO SHOW OUR SUPPORT AND TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU IT DIDN'T ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SAYING NINE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
START BURKE -- THERE'S A NUMBER
OF SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS DO YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON THOSE.
WELL I THINK THERE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS -- WE ACCEPT THEM --
THERE WAS -- SOME CONCERN ABOUT.
THE LENGTH OF THE EXEMPTION SO
WE DEALT WITH THAT WITH THE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS ON COMMITTEE.
SEEN IN CEREBELLAR YOU LIKE
CLOTHES.
THANK YOU EVERYBODY -- ORIGINAL
VOTE ON THIS ONE APPROPRIATE
TIME COMES THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION -- SENATOR
HUESO FILE ITEM THREE SB.
FOUR TWENTY TWO WOULD YOU LIKE
TO OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS --
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME PERCENT
SB.
FOUR TWENTY TWO I WILL BE
ACCEPTED IN -- THE AMENDED
LANGUAGE WHICH WILL BRING OUR
BILL INTO COMPLIANCE WITH
SECTION FORTY ONE OF THE TAXI.
REVENUE AND TAXATION CODE.
SB FORTY FORTY TWO CREATES.
AN EMPLOYER TAX CREDIT WHICH
WILL ALLOW QUALIFIED EMPLOYER
WHO HIRES A FORMERLY
INCARCERATED YOUTH [inaudible]
FULL TIME.
OKAY A CREDIT IN AMOUNT OF EQUAL
OF 50% OF QUALIFIED WAGES PAID
BY THE TAXPAYER.
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT IT COSTS
ROUGHLY SIXTY THOUSAND A YEAR TO
INCARCERATE A PRISONER IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IF THIS PROGRAM KEEPS.
TWELVE YOUNG EX OFFENDERS FROM
RE OFFENDING THEN THIS PROGRAM
ACROSS THE STATE NOTHING IN TAX
REVENUE.
GIVEN THE SOCIAL BENEFITS
ASSOCIATED WITH.
AN EX OFFENDER NOT GOING BACK TO
PRISON ULTIMATELY THE SAVINGS
WOULD BE EVEN GREATER.
AS MANY OF YOU IF YOU KNOW.
THE A NUMBER OF AMERICANS OF
COMING CUT CONTACT WITH THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
HAS A X. INCREASE EXPONENTIALLY
BETWEEN NINETEEN EIGHTY AND TWO
THOUSAND NINE CALIFORNIA'S.
IN THAT PERIOD CALIFORNIA'S
PRISON POPULATION INCREASE FIVE
HUNDRED AND 83%. FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT GO TO PRISON --
SOMETIMES WITH -- MINOR OFFENSES
THEY CAN -- THEY CAN FIND
THEMSELVES IN A IN A SITUATION
WHERE THEY THEY PAY THAT PENALTY
FOR THE REST OF THEIR LIVES.
ANY SENTENCE IN OUR SOCIETY IS A
LIFE SENTENCE WHICH USUALLY
RESULTS IN THESE KIDS --
RETURNING TO PRISON AT AN
ENORMOUS COST TO TAXPAYERS.
WE HAVE -- TO BELIEVE THIS IN A
SOCIETY WE HAVE TO BELIEVE IN
REDEMPTION AND GIVE OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE AN OPPORTUNITY TO TO
REFORM THEMSELVES TO RECAST
THEMSELVES.
TO RE ENTER SOCIETY IS
SUCCESSFULLY.
AND HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
A LIVING.
THIS BILL WILL -- THE ONE EXTRA
STEP IN OUR OUR PROCESS OF HOT
HAVING TO REFORM A YOUNG PEOPLE
IN OUR COUNTRY AND GIVEN THEM A
PATH -- AND WROTE A NEW
DIRECTION AND A NEW PATH TO
ACHIEVING THE AMERICAN DREAM.
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY I
HAVE A READ AT IS REPRESENTS
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE YEARS
JOINING ME THANK YOU.
THE YOU WITH YOUR PERMISSION
MADAM CHAIR.
WIN ASSISTANCE SUPPORT AT THANK
YOU CHAIR MEMBERS READ OUT
ASSEMBLY HALF THE LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS IS FOURTEEN
COURSE THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SERVING THE VULNERABLE
POPULATION AND HELPING TO REMOVE
TO KEEP BARRIERS AND THANKS TO
YOUR LEADERSHIP OVER THE YEARS
YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE
FUNDING TO THE LOCAL CORES THAT
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO REMOVE THESE
TWO BARRIERS.
ONE RELATING TO EDUCATION
TYPICALLY A LOT OF THE PEOPLE WE
WORK WITH OR DROP OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL.
A ONE OF OUR GOALS IS TO GIVE
THEM A HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATION.
TWO THEY TYPICALLY DON'T HAVE A
LOT OF JOB EXPERIENCE AND SO
WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO DO IS
ACTUALLY GIVEN THAT JOB
EXPERIENCE BY GETTING THEM OUT
ON PROJECTS AND SOON AND THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO GIVE THEM BOTH THE
JOB EXPERIENCE.
AND THE EDUCATION THEY NEED TO
BE PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF SOCIETY.
HOWEVER WE HAVE INCREASINGLY
SEEN A PROBLEM WITH SOME OF OUR
CORE MEMBERS WHO -- WERE WITHIN
THE PAROLE SYSTEM AND BASICALLY
WHAT THAT MEANS IS WHEN THEY
LEAVE CARS -- PROGRAM AND THEY
GO TO A PROSPECTIVE EMPLOYER
THEY'RE FINDING THAT THAT IS AN
ADDITIONAL BARRIER.
THAT EVEN THOUGH THEY'VE GONE
THROUGH OUR PROGRAM THEY'RE NOT
ABLE TO GET THAT KIND OF JOB.
IT IS THEREFORE TODAY WE
APPRECIATE THE THE CENTER HUESO
IS LEADERSHIP ON THIS MEASURE
WHICH WE THINK WILL GO A LONG
WAY.
AND REMOVING THAT BARRIER IN
CREATING AN INCENTIVE FOR SOME
THE FOLKS WHO COME TO OUR
PROGRAM TO GET A JOB AND BE
GAINFULLY EMPLOYED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
CNN COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE DOCTOR QUIRK.
SO WE HAVE SOME AREAS OF THE
STATE OUR PENINSULA THERE'S A 3%
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE THE EAST BAY
IT'S AROUND -- FOUR FIVE WHERE
IN YOUR AREA HOWEVER IT'S
PROBABLY AROUND 20%.
I WOULD THINK THAT THIS TAX
CREDIT.
MIGHT MAKE SENSE WELL THE
QUESTION IS ARE YOU CREATING
JOBS AND TO THE EXTENT YOUR
GRADING THEM DO THEY GO -- TO
THE PEOPLE YOU'RE TRYING -- TO
TO REACH -- AND I JUST THINK
THAT YOUR AREA OF THE STATE
NEEDS A LOT MORE THAN MY AREA OF
THE STATE BUT THERE'S YOU KNOW I
I ONE THING YOU MIGHT THINK
ABOUT IS DOES IT MAKES MORE
SENSE TO DO THIS IN AN AREA.
I WOULD BE WORRIED THAT.
FRANKLY IN MY AREA WHERE THERE
ARE ALREADY PEOPLE.
DESPERATE TO HIRE.
AND THE BUILDING TRADES ARE
ABSOLUTELY TRYING TO GET
EVERYONE THEY CAN AND THEY'RE
WILLING TO TAKE PEOPLE WHO HAVE --
FELONIES ON THEIR RECORD AND IN
FACT -- I KNOW SOME PEOPLE IN
THE CARPENTERS WHO.
WHO BASICALLY HAD THEIR WHITE
LIGHTS?
LIVES TURNED AROUND.
I WOULD THINK THAT THIS IS
APPROPRIATE IN SOME AREAS OF THE
STATE BUT PROBABLY NOT IN MY
HOME TOWN AWAY.
THE AREA I REPRESENT.
AND A COMMON WELL I APPRECIATE
THAT VERY MUCH AND REGARDLESS OF
WHERE THESE INDIVIDUALS LIVE THE
STATISTIC IS PRETTY -- EQUAL
ACROSS THE STATE THAT THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE TEND TO RECIDIVISM.
AT ABOUT AT A RATE OF ABOUT 70%
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY LIVE IN
THE STATE SO.
YEAH BUT WOULD IT.
WOULD THIS EFFECT THAT
RECIDIVISM RATE IN A PLACE WHERE
I CAN ASSURE YOU WHENEVER I GO
TO A SMALL BUSINESS IN MY AREA.
THEY'RE ALWAYS SAYING LOOK WHAT
WE WANT.
IS SOMEONE WHO WILL COME IN ON
TIME AND DO WHAT THEY'RE TOLD
IT'S A SIMPLE AS THAT WE WANT
PEOPLE AT THIS VERY BASIC LEVEL.
AND THEY SAY THEY ARE WILLING TO
TAKE ON PEOPLE LIKE THIS SO.
OUR OUR BILL IS A PILOT.
WE WANT WHAT WE IT'S A PILOT
PROGRAM IT HELLO OKAY DATE.
SO IT'S NOT REYES THE PILOT
GOING TO TAKE PLACE -- STATE
WIDE [inaudible]
SO. TWO YEARS SUNSET YEAH.
ARM WILL YOU BE COLLECTING THE
DATA WE NEED TO SEE WHERE IT'S
EFFECTIVE IN WHERE IT ISN'T.
I GUESS THAT'S ONE OF ASIAN AND
ASIAN SALEABLE TO US BUT AT THE
BILL DOESN'T NECESSARILY HAVE
THAT REQUIREMENT TO COLLECT.
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT YOU LOOK AT
GETTING THE DATA TO SEE.
AND I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY IT'S
EASY FOR ME TO SAY THIS IS
HARDER TO PUT IT INTO ACTUAL
LANGUAGE.
BUT IF YOU -- IF THIS BILL DOES
GO FORWARD I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO SEE WHERE IT'S
USEFUL AND WHERE IT ISN'T AND I
SUSPECT THAT THERE ARE PLACES IN
THE STATE.
WHERE IT'LL BE MUCH MORE
EFFECTIVE THAN IN OTHER PLACES
IN PARTICULAR I THINK MORE IN
YOUR DISTRICT THAN MINE?
BECAUSE YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE JUST
LOOKING FOR AND WHERE I AM
PARTICULARLY IN THE BUILDING
TRADES JUST LOOKING FOR SOMEONE.
TO TO FILL THESE POSITIONS AND
THEY'RE WILLING TO TAKE PEOPLE
AND AND HAVE TAKEN PEOPLE WHO DO
HAVE RECORDS.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
WITH ME ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS.
WHAT IS THE CURRENT PLAN FOR
MEASURING EFFICACY OF THE PILOT
SO THAT AFTER TWO YEARS WE CAN
DETERMINE?
IF IT'S EFFECTIVE AND IF WE'RE
GONNA ROLL IT OUT.
WELL WE HAVE A I'M BEEN
EXPLAINED THAT THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD WILL.
BE PROVIDING THAT INFORMATION.
TO WHAT WHAT INFORMATION.
THE HA HA THE UTILIZATION RATE
OF THE PROGRAM OKAY.
AND THAT THAT WOULD GIVE US
ENOUGH INFORMATION TO ASSESS HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE.
EMPLOYED IN THE PROGRAM AND HOW
LONG THEY STAY IN THE PROGRAM.
IN CERTAIN AS PART OF KIND OF
THIS COMMITTEE'S FRAMEWORK WE
PART OF WHAT PEOPLE SUBMIT IS
KIND OF A A PLAN FOR MEASUREMENT
AND DATA COLLECTION CRIMES TO
SECTION FORTY ONE IS THE
INTENTION.
OF WHAT THE GOOD WHAT THE GOALS
ARE THAT'S WHAT SECTION FORTY
ONE BASICALLY **** FOR METRIC
SINGLES IT'S NOT NECESSARILY
DATA COLLECTION.
GOT IT IS THE PROPOSED METRIC
SINGLES.
YEAH I WOULD DEFINITELY I WOULD
WILL ECHOED DOCTOR CORKS COMMENT
THAT ASSESSING WHETHER OR NOT
THIS IS AN EFFECTIVE PROGRAM
ISN'T JUST.
YOU KNOW THE NUMBER OF FOLKS
THAT HAVE TAKEN IT UP FOR THE
NUMBER OF COMPANIES THAT HAVE
TAKEN IT UP BATES.
ACTUAL DATA ON IT RICK
RECIDIVISM.
AND AS HIRING RATES COMPARED TO
BASELINE SO FOR US THAT DB DATA
WOULD QUALIFY FOR SECTION.
FORTY ONE SUGGEST THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THAT TAKEN IT UP WOULD
QUALIFY AS A MEASUREMENT OKAY.
YEAH I WOULD.
I KNOW YOU PI LIKE MORE DETAILS
WHICH WOULD BE FANTASTIC I THINK
BUT AND AND NOT SOMETHING THE
AUTHOR CAN CONSIDER AND IS OF I
THINK A QUALIFIED COMMENT.
HOWEVER I WILL TELL YOU THAT AS
SOMEBODY YES THE CARPENTERS DO
REGULARLY WANT TO AYE HI ARE
OPEN. TO HIRING THOSE WHO HAVE
BEEN INCARCERATED HOWEVER THERE
ARE.
A PLETHORA OF OTHER INDUSTRIES
THAT DO NOT PARTICIPATE IN THOSE
PROGRAMS AND ANYTHING THAT WE
CAN DO TO MAKE SURE.
THAT YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN WHO
HAVE SERVED THEIR TIME AND NOW A
LOT OF WHICH YOU HAVE SOFT
SKILLS WERE TALKING ABOUT IN THE
BUDGET -- WORD -- GIVING MONEY
TO IS A PROGRAM CALLED THE
CHALLENGER PROGRAM WHICH IS
ACTUALLY TO DO SOMETHING JUST
LIKE THIS IT'S TO TAKE KIDS WHO
ARE COMING OUT OF JUVENILE
FACILITIES AND MAKE SURE.
THAT THEY HAVE TRAINING WHILE
THEY'RE THERE SO THAT THEY GO
STRAIGHT INTO A JOB BUT FOR
THOSE KIDS WHO ARE NOT PART OF
THAT THREE HUNDRED BED PILOT
PROGRAM.
THERE ARE STILL A LOT OF YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO DON'T WHO ARE GOING
TO BE CARPENTERS WHO ARE WILLING
PART PART OF THAT ARE PART OF
PIPEFITTERS OR SOME OF THE OTHER
PEOPLE WHO ARE WILLING TO TAKE
FOLKS THAT ARE THAT HAVE BEEN
INCARCERATED.
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO ENCOURAGE
A NEW PATH.
AND THE PATH TO RECIDIVISM IS
NOT JUST A PATH OF TRAINING
INSIDE THE PRISONS BUT IT IS
ALSO A PATH TO WHERE THE YOU GO
AFTERWARDS.
YET NO LIKE I NEVER SAY HEAR YOU
ON THAT I THINK.
WHAT I WOULD CHALLENGE AND AND
NOT JUST YOU I THINK FOR ALL OF
US RIGHT THE WE NEVER HAVE
ENOUGH RESOURCES TO DO ALL THE
THINGS THAT WE WANT TO DO SO?
IT'S INCUMBENT UPON US TO DO
WHATEVER WE CAN TO MEASURE IT SO
THAT WE CAN SAY.
YOU KNOW IS THIS PILOT PROGRAM
THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY TO SPEND
THESE DOLLARS OR IS THERE
NOTICES CHALLENGER PROGRAM A
MORE EFFECTIVELY DOUBLE AND I
THINK I WOULD EVEN JUST THE MOST
MINIMAL DATA FROM FTP SAYING
THAT THIS MANY COMPANIES TOOK IN.
A HIRED YOUNG PEOPLE WHO WHO ARE
HAVE BEEN THROUGH REHABILITATION
WILL ACTUALLY GIVE YOU A MEASURE
OF HOW MANY PEOPLE VERSUS HOW
MANY DIDN'T LAST YEAR.
SO I THINK THAT'S A START YES IF
THEY WANT TO WORK WITH C. C. R.
AND SEE IF THAT THERE'S A WAY TO
COLLECT MORE DETAILED
INFORMATION OR PROBATION TO WORK
ON MORE DETAILED INFORMATION I
THINK THAT IS.
AS DOCTOR CLARK SAID A MUCH MORE
COMPLICATED PROCESS THERE'S
PRIVACY ISSUES TRUST ME WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THIS -- AND
THEY'VE HAD REPORTS FROM
PROBATION DEPARTMENT OF THIS
YEAR TO TALK ABOUT THE KIND OF
THE CHALLENGES OF COLLECTING
THAT DATA.
BUT I THINK FROM FTV AT LEAST AS
A START TO KNOW IF FIVE
COMPANIES USED IT UTILIZED IT OR
A HUNDRED COMPANIES UTILIZED IT
WILL AT LEAST GIVE US AN IDEA
INTO YOUR SUPPORT GOING DOWN THE
RIGHT PATH.
AND THAT IS IN THEIR SECTION ONE
AMENDMENT THAT IS NOT IN THERE
NOW BUT THAT THEY ARE WORKING ON
AN AND IF I CAN JUST -- YOU KNOW
NOW THAT I'VE HAD A CHANCE TO
KIND OF UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU'RE JUST JUST TO GIVE
YOU A LITTLE HISTORY OF WHERE WE
CAME UP WITH THIS BILL -- THIS
STATE USED TO HAVE AN ENTERPRISE
ZONE PROGRAM THAT -- WE LARGELY
DISMANTLED IN TERMS OF HOW --
WHAT?
WHAT BUSINESSES ARE ENTITLED TO
A TAX CREDIT AND IN WHERE THAT
THAT IS CONDUCTED THAT WAS THERE
WAS A REFORM THAT HAPPEN AROUND --
TWENTY THIRTEEN AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE -- IN TERMS OF
GATHERING GAS GATHERING DATA
THROUGH THAT PROGRAM STILL
EXISTS.
THAT'S HOW WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ASSESS HOW MUCH OF THOSE TAX
DOLLARS ARE ACTUALLY BEING DRAWN.
AND AND USED IN UNDERSERVED
AREAS.
WE HAD ORIGINALLY ENVISIONED
THAT THERE WOULD BE ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND DRAWN DOWN
WHICH IS I MEAN THE NUMBER USED
TO BE CLOSER TO NINE HUNDRED
MILLION -- WE THAT NUMBER WE
EXPECTED WILL GO DOWN TO ABOUT
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION IT HAS
ACTUALLY GONE DOWN TO ABOUT A
HUNDRED MILLION.
THOSE ARE MONIES THAT WERE
TENSION LEE -- INTENDED TO HELP
CREATE EMPLOYMENT HELP CREATE
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE A LOW INCOME PEOPLE AND%
UNDERSERVED AREAS.
SO THIS PROGRAM WOULD SIMPLY --
WORKED INTO THE STRUCTURE OF
THAT ENTIRE ENTERPRISE.
ZONE -- PROGRAM THAT STILL
LARGELY INTACT SO WOULD ALLOW US
TO TRACK.
WHAT'S BEING DRAWN DOWN WHERE
AND FOR WHAT PURPOSE.
SO -- ALL WE'RE DOING IS
BASICALLY ANSWERED IN THIS
POLICY AND TO THAT TAX CODE.
AND THAT -- FRAMEWORK THAT
ALREADY EXISTS AND HOPING THAT
WE GET WE GET SOME RESULTS THAT
THE PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO ARE DRAWN
THIS PROGRAM STAY OUT OF PRISON
GET A JOB.
AND ESTABLISH THAT HISTORY. TO
EVENTUALLY HELP THEM -- TO ONCE
THEY GET -- BEYOND A CERTAIN AGE
LIMIT. TO GO OFF ON THEIR OWN
ESTABLISH THAT WORK HISTORY SO I
THINK EVERYBODY EVERYTHING THAT
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT THIS
PROGRAM CAN BE.
NOT ONLY MARKETED BUT UTILIZED
EMPLOYED AND AND TRACK IS
ALREADY IN PLACE UNDER OUR OUR
STATES.
TAX CODE AND ADMINISTRATIVE
POLICIES -- WE JUST WANNA --
GIVE THIS A TRY I THINK -- THIS
BILL WOULD GIVE US.
ENOUGH TIME TO PUT IT INTO A
FACT TO SEE IF IT IS UTILIZED
AND CONSIDER LOOK AT LATER DATE
TO SEE HOW SUCCESSFUL IT IS. TO
SEE IF WE WANT EMPLOY CONTINUE
TO PLAY IN THE FUTURE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DOCTOR FORGET A QUESTION -- I'LL
BE VERY BRIEF.
I THINK WHAT WE BOTH WANT TO DO
IS SEE WHAT HAPPENED THE TWO
YEARS BEFORE.
AND WHAT HAPPENED TO TWO YEARS
LATER AND IT'S NOT JUST -- THE
AMOUNT TAKEN UP IT'S WAS THERE
AN INCREASE ARE WE REALLY
SERVING MORE PEOPLE.
ARE WE JUST SEEING THAT THE
PLACES THAT ALREADY HAVE LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT ARE JUST USING IT A
LOT AND PLACES THAT.
DON'T DON'T USE IT.
AND SO THERE'S NOT THAT MUCH OF
A CHANGE THAT'S THE MAIN THING I
THINK WE'RE BOTH CONCERNED ABOUT
WE WANT TO SEE CHANGE.
WHERE PARTICULARLY PLACES WITH
HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT SEE A A
MEASURE?
OF INCREASING JOBS.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
AND I'D BE I'D BE.
MORE THAN GLAD TO SUBMIT A
LETTER TO THE GENERAL JOURNAL TO
THAT EFFECT IF THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WOULD PLEASE YOU SURE THANK
YOU.
AND ALSO JUST FOR THE RECORD
THIS IS BASED ON AND IT'S ALSO
BASED ON THE NEW EMPLOYMENT
CREDIT WHICH THEIR NUMBER FOR
VISIONS TO GUARD AGAINST ANY
SORT OF ABUSE.
OF USING THE CREDIT SO THAT IS
IN PLACE AS WELL IN THE BILL.
I WOULD LIKE TO TELL YOU THAT
FOR SOMEONE FROM MY COMMUNITY.
SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT -- PEOPLE
SAY ALL THE TIME THAT THEY BE
WILLING. TO HIRE EX OFFENDERS
AND WHEN IT ACTUALLY COMES TIME
TO DO IT THEY DON'T ALWAYS DO IT
AS MAFIC THEY RARELY DO.
AND SO ANY INCENTIVE WE CAN GIVE
EMPLOYERS TO MOVE THEM IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION I AM HAPPY. TO
BE PART OF AND SO IT WHEN THE
TIME COMES I WOULD LOVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE A CO AUTHOR ON
THIS.
AND WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THE JUST SIMPLY I THINK THIS IS
GOING TO BE AN ADDITIONAL TOOL.
IN THE TOOL BELT OF OF THIS
COMMUNITY.
IN IN IN WORKING WITH OUR LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE AT WORK WITH
EDUCATING THESE YOUNG PEOPLE
PREPARING THEM PROVIDING OF
TRAINING.
THEY SAY THEIR NUMBER ONE
BARRIER TO GETTING THESE -- A
YOUNG PEOPLE PLACED ON A JOB IS
THEIR PAST HISTORY.
AND AND GETTING BEYOND THAT IS
VERY DIFFICULT AT THAT LEVEL AND
OUR LOCAL CONSERVATION COURSE OR
STATEWIDE.
THEY'RE ALSO IN THE BAY AREA AND
THEY ALSO -- BRING FORTH THE
SAME CHALLENGES.
ON ALL.
THEY THEY BOTH -- EXPRESS THE
SAME CHALLENGES TO THAT THAT
SPECIFIC COHORTS SO.
WE'RE GIVEN A SHOT WE'RE HOPING
THAT THIS WILL BE SUCCESSFUL WE
HOPE THAT THIS COULD -- BEGIN --
A SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM OF
REVERSING A TREND IN HELPING
PEOPLE TO TO GET ON A MORE
PRODUCTIVE PATH IN THEIR LIVES.
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU
THIS ITEM FOR TESTIMONY ONLY BUT
WE APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION
THANK YOU -- WOMEN FILE ITEM ONE
SB THIRTY FOUR SENATOR WIENER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN
.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR -- I'M TO IMPRISONING
SENATE BILL -- THIRTY FOUR THE
DENNIS PERON A BROWNIE MARY ACTS --
WHICH WILL ENSURE THAT --
COMPASSIONATE CARE MEDICAL
CANNABIS PROGRAMS PROGRAMS THAT.
ARE GIVE.
OCT MEDICAL CANNABIS AWAY FOR
FREE TO LOW INCOME PATIENTS.
ARE CAN CONTINUE TO SURVIVE --
THIS.
MEASURE I DID PASS OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR -- AND OUT
OF THE ENTIRE LEGISLATURE WITH
OVERWHELMING BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
UNFORTUNATELY OUR FORMER
GOVERNOR BE TODAS SO WE ARE BACK
BECAUSE THIS IS ABOUT.
ENSURING PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO
MEDICINE ARE WE WILL BE -- AS
AUTHOR AMENDMENTS MAKING
AMENDMENTS ARE CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT WAS REQUESTED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS SO WE ARE
HAVING THOSE DRAFTED RIGHT NOW.
SO COLLEAGUES FOR THOSE WHO
DON'T KNOW BACK IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES -- DURING THE HEIGHT OF
THE THE WORST OF THE AIDS
EPIDEMIC IN SAN FRANCISCO.
OUR COMPASSION PROGRAMS CAME
INTO EXISTENCE TO GOD SURE THAT
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO THEIR
MEDICINE -- OVER TIME THESE
PROGRAMS HAVE -- PROVIDED ACCESS
TO MEDICINE TO SO MANY PEOPLE
LIVING WITH HIV CANCER.
MANY VETERANS WITH PTSD AND
OTHER PROBLEMS WHO HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO STOP USING
PHARMACEUTICALS AND OPIOIDS AS A
RESULT OF THIS.
OUR CHILDREN WITH RARE DISEASES
AND SAW AN ENORMOUS NUMBER OF
ELEMENTS OF FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
LOW INCOME WHO CAN BENEFIT --
WITH THE LEGALIZATION OF ADULT
USE OF CANNABIS -- WHAT WE'VE
SEEN AS -- I THOUGHT CANNABIS IS
NOT CHEAP.
ARE WHEN YOU GET IT THE LEGAL
WAY IT'S NOT CHEAP.
I AND IT WHEN PROP SIXTY FOUR
WAS PASSED WE BELIEVE THIS WAS
AN ADVISER AND THAT -- THE HI
STATE TAXES WERE IMPOSED ON
THESE COMPASSION PROGRAMS WHICH
OF COURSE HAVE NO REVENUE
BECAUSE THEY DON'T SELL ANYTHING.
SPENCER COMPASSION PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN CLOSING DOWN I AND MY
DISTRICT AND OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE BECAUSE THEY DO NOT HAVE
REVENUE TO PAY.
THE TAXES AND WHAT THIS DOES IS
IT REDUCES ACCESS -- BY VETERANS
AND PEOPLE LIVING WITH HIV AND
OTHER PEOPLE -- BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T AFFORD -- THAT OUGHT TO
PAY FOR WHAT IS LEGAL -- AND
THEY END UP GOING ON THE BLACK
MARKET WHICH OF COURSE NONE OF
US WANTS FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS AND IS NOT GOOD FOR THE
CONSUMER.
IT'S NOT GOOD FOR THE STATE.
I SAID THIS BILL -- WILL RELIEVE --
WILL WAIVE TAXES -- FOR THESE --
PROGRAMS I WILL SAY THAT I
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS
TECHNICALLY -- A REDUCTION IN
TAXES OR TAX CREDIT PROGRAM BUT
TO BE VERY CLEAR.
THESE ARE ILLUSORY TAX
COLLECTIONS THESE.
THESE TAXES WILL NEVER --
ACTUALLY EXISTS BECAUSE THESE
PROGRAMS WILL SIMPLY SHUT DOWN
TO THE STATE IS NOT GOING TO GET
EVEN IF WE DON'T PASS THIS IS
NOT GOING TO GET ANY OF THESE
TOXICITIES ARE IMAGINARY TAXES.
BUT I UNDER TOTALLY UNDERSTAND
THE PROTOCOL TO COMMITTEE WHICH
I SUPPORT -- SO -- WE HAVE A
BROAD SUPPORT -- AND LIKE I SAID
THIS TO RECEIVE BROAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT -- HAS EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY LAST YEAR AND THIS YEAR --
SO I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE WITH
ME TODAY TO TESTIFY ARE AMY
JENKINS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
AND RYAN MILLER WITH OPERATION
EVEN DOCTOR COMPASSIONATE CARE
PROGRAM SERVING VETERANS IN THE
EAST BAY.
HI MY NAME IS RYAN MILLER IN
MARINE CORPS VETERAN AND FOUNDER
OF OPERATION FEEDBACK EDUCATING
VETERANS ABOUT CANNABIS.
WE WORK TO PREVENT VETERANS
SUICIDE AN OPIATE OVERDOSE TO
RECURRING SOCIAL SUPPORT GROUPS
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH CANNABIS
DISPENSARIES.
THROUGHOUT THE BAY AREA AND
RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
THROUGH THE FIVE YEARS OF OUR
WORK IN A COMMUNITY THAT SUFFERS
FROM GREATER THAN TWENTY TWO
SUICIDES DALY.
WE HAVEN'T LOST A SINGLE SOUL TO
SELF HARM [inaudible]
IT'S WORKING.
SINCE PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR HAS
BEEN IMPLEMENTED IT'S BEEN
RADICALLY MORE DIFFICULT TO
SOURCE.
BILLING PRIVATELY DONATED
CANNABIS PRODUCTS.
DUE TO AN AN EXISTING PATHWAY TO
COMPLIANT DONATIONS AND DUE TO
AN UNDUE IN.
OVERWHELMING TAX BURDEN.
COMPASSION PROGRAMS LIKE
OPERATION EVAC ARE FORCED TO
SEEK SUPPLY FROM THE UNREGULATED.
UNTESTED AND UNSAFE TRADITIONAL
MARKET PLACE.
SB THIRTY FOUR IS HERE TO REMEDY
THAT.
A BIG PART OF MY WORK WITH
VETERANS IS INVITING A POSITION
OF GRATITUDE AND SO I'M HERE TO
EXPRESS GRATITUDE TO EACH OF YOU.
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS
BILL.
GRATITUDE FOR SENATOR WIENER AND
HIS STAFF FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP.
GRATITUDE TO THE POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION THAT WITHDREW THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
AND GRATITUDE TO EVERY VETERAN
THAT SITTING BEHIND ME.
AND EVERY VETERAN OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT IS DESPERATELY DEPENDING ON
YOUR DECISION.
WERE ASKING AND BEGGING AND
PRAYING.
THAT YOU DON'T LEAVE US BEHIND
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION A VERY PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THIS LEGISLATION --
WE TO FEEL THAT THIS IS A VERY
VERY -- SIGNIFICANT ISSUE ALL OF
OUR EXISTING RETAILERS OPERATED
COMPASSIONATE CARE PROGRAMS
PRIOR TO THE ENACTMENT OF
PROPOSITION.
SIXTY FOUR AND WHAT THEY ARE
HEARING FROM A QUITE A NUMBER OF
THEIR MEDICINAL PATIENTS IS THAT
THEY CAN -- NO LONGER AFFORD TO
ACQUIRE THE PRODUCT IN THESE --
THESE LEGAL OPERATIONS BECAUSE
THOSE COMPASSIONATE CARE
PROGRAMS ARE GOING AWAY OR THEY
HAVE BEEN SEVERELY RESTRICTED TO
DUE TO THE HIGH TAX RATES I'M
CERTAINLY IT IS THE OBJECTIVE OF
THE STATE WE BELIEVE -- TO HAVE
ENCOURAGE -- PATIENTS MEDICINAL
PATIENTS TO GO INTO THE
COMPLAINT MARKET WE HAVE SOME OF
THE MOST RIGOROUS TESTING AND
QUALITY CONTROL STANDARDS IN THE
STATE -- GOING TO THE UNLICENSED
MARKET PUTS THESE PATIENTS AN
UNDUE HARM.
SO WE WOULD CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY -- FOR OUR
MEMBERS AND AND WHO RELY ON ON
MEDICINAL CANNABIS SAFE
MEDICINAL CANNABIS AND AND
CERTAINLY FROM OUR RETAILERS WHO
ARE REALLY LOOKING TO REINSTATE
THESE PROGRAMS AND A VERY ROBUST
FASHION SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ADDITIONAL ESSES IN SUPPORT.
HELLO LOPEZ CASE STREET
CONSULTING ON BEHALF OF FLOW
KANA AND THE SILICON VALLEY
CANNABIS ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
KAREN L<c.cyan>G ABOVE THE CITY AND</c>
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT.
HI JASON BROWN ON BEHALF OF A
HUMBLE COUNTY GROWERS ALLIANCE
FOR INSOFAR AS WELL THANK YOU.
TRACY STEVENS ON BEHALF OF NOR
CAL CANNABIS ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
EMILY HERE'S ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
WE NEED TO ON BEHALF OF THE
QUALITY CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
BLAKE JOHNSON HOMEPATH STAGES OF
YOUR MARK HERE STRONG SUPPORT.
CATHERINE ANY RETIRED UNITED
STATES MARINE SOCIAL WORKER SAN
FRANCISCO.
AND MEMBER OF OPERATION NEED
THAT.
BECAUSE OF WHAT RYAN'S DONE OVER
THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE TO ME I HAVE
SO MANY FRIENDS FROM VIETNAM
THAT IT DIED BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
HAVE A PROGRAM AROUND WHEN THEY
CAME BACK.
THAT TAUGHT PEOPLE HOW TO
MEDICATE MEDITATE.
LEARNING HOW TO MEDITATE IN
TEACHING THESE OLDER AND YOUNGER
VETS THAT IS REALLY SAVING LIVES
AND BEING OUT WOULD GET THEIR
MEDICATION WITHOUT HAPPENED A
SPEND ALL THEIR EXTRA MONEY.
AFTER PAYING THEIR RENT IN SAN
FRANCISCO -- IT MEANS EVERYTHING
TO THEM -- I'M LUCKY I CAN STILL
WORK IN NOW BUT MANY VETERANS
CAN'T GET A JOB AND CAN'T WORK
ANYMORE. FOR VARIOUS REASONS AND
NOW THEY CAN'T THE I I KNOW.
THAT THEY DIDN'T MEAN FOR THIS
LAW TO CHANGE AND AFFECT US THIS
WAY IT'S A SECONDARY MISSED
ENOUGH.
THING THAT HAPPENED AFTER IT WAS
LEGALIZED NO ONE WAS THINKING
AHEAD ABOUT US THAT WE'RE
ALREADY WORKING SO HARD SO LONG.
FOR TWO FIFTEEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR CONSIDERING US -- AND
PLEASE VOTE.
IN OUR FAVOR FOR SAVING LIVES
RUNS SAVED THOUSANDS OF LIVES
ALREADY.
THINK THANK YOU FOR COMING TODAY
NAME AND AFFILIATION ONLY PRETTY
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SUCH A
MARTINEZ -- I'M A NAVY VETERAN --
TENTH GENERATION CALIFORNIAN AND
DISABLED VETERAN A MEMBER OF
OPERATION YOU BACK AS WELL.
THESE COMPASSIONATE PROGRAMS
WILL HELP TO TURN OUR SWORDS
INTO PLOWSHARES SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE OUR SERVICE THE
COMPASSION.
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
EVERYONE THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY BUT NAME AND
AFFILIATION ONLY PLEASE.
VINCENT MARTINEZ -- VETERANS
WALK AND TALK NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
I'D LIKE TO INVITE AND YOU YOU
GUYS ANA HIKE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RICHARD MANNING I
MEAN A SERVICE RECORD BROKEN
DISABLED IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
I HOPE YOU PASS BECAUSE AMONG
THOSE THAT TO ACTUALLY NEED THIS
CANNABIS AND I CAN'T AFFORD
REGULATION HERE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LIZ THE THIRTIES -- U. S. NAVY
VETERAN -- I STARTED OUT AS A
PATIENT IN A COMPASSION PROGRAM
AND IT HELPED ME GET MYSELF
BETTER AND NOW I AM A CHAPTER
LEADER HELPING OTHERS GET BETTER.
I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY FOUR THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ON HOW THE SAUDIS
ON BEHALF OF UNITED CAMPUS BINS
ASSOCIATION CAN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MY NAME'S NEIL YARBOROUGH I'M A
MARINE CORPS COMBAT THAT I WENT
OVER AND FOUGHT FOR EACH ONE OF
YOUR GUISES FREEDOMS OVER IN
IRAQ.
EVEN YEARS GERMAN THAT'S LOOKING
AT YOUR COMPUTER RIGHT NOW AND
THINK IT'S MORE IMPORTANT.
THAN LOOKING AT ME UP HERE
TALKING TO YOU.
I WAS ON THIRTY TWO DIFFERENT
MEDS.
AND NOW I USE CANNABIS THAT TO
RELIEVE THAT.
I TRIED TO COMMIT SUICIDE ON THE
VA MEDS.
HE HAS REALLY NEED TO THINK
ABOUT THAT WHEN YOU VOTE HERE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
NAME AND AFFILIATION ONLY PLEASE
SABRINA FANDRICH ON BEHALF OF
BERKELEY PATIENTS GROUP IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI DOUGLAS REAL ON BEHALF OF
MISSION COMPASSION COMPASSION
PROGRAM IN THE EAST BAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI I'M DAVE CASH SHOWS UP FRONT
LINES ARE AT DESERT STORM.
NINETY ONE I'VE BEEN SEVEN FOR
PTSD FOR TWENTY ONE YEARS THESE
GUYS PUT ARMS AROUND ME. ELEVEN
THE DEBT FOR THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR ME.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
THAT AFTERNOON NICOLE RATHER ON
BEHALF OF EASE AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
SONNY WELSH I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF HERITAGE HOLDING RINSED ON
SUPPORT.
SHOT KERN AND WE FOUR HOURS
THANK YOU STRONG SUPPORT.
CHRISTOPHER SAID A NAVY VET
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
I GOT LESS BOND MURPHY WITH WITH
MAP STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
OKAY.
OUR COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SENATOR YOU MENTIONED THE
GOVERNOR VETOED THIS PREVIOUSLY.
I THINK THE REASONS HE'S HE'S HE
THOUGHT IT CONFLICT OF THE
STANDARD TO ROP SIXTY FOUR I
MEAN HOW DO YOU.
RESPOND TO THAT.
YEAH WE DON'T -- WE DON'T AGREE
WITH THAT -- I DON'T THINK GOD A
FEW TALK TO ANYONE WHO PUT
TOGETHER IN NEGOTIATED OR
CAMPAIGN FOR PROP SIXTY FORTY
SEVEN WITH A YOUR INTENTION. TO
TAXES AYE AYE I'VE NEVER MET
ANYONE WHO'S WHO THOUGHT THAT
WAS THE INTENTION -- AND THEN IN
TERMS OF DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
HAVING -- MEDICINAL CARD VERSUS
A PHYSICIAN RECOMMENDATION --
THE MEDICAL CARDS ARE ICY IT'S
IT'S NOT ALWAYS EASY FOR PEOPLE.
TO ACTUALLY JUMP FROM -- AND
PARTICULARLY FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SEVERE MEDICAL PROBLEMS -- IT'S
HARDER THAN IT SHOULD BE -- AND
IT WOULD -- AND UP EXCLUDING A
LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
DESPERATE.
NEED -- IF THEY'RE REQUIRED TO
ACTUALLY GO AND GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS TO GET A CARD -- AS
OPPOSED TO HAVING A PHYSICIAN
SAY I RECOMMEND THIS PERSON
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
BOUGHT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS FOR
TESTIMONY ONLY TODAY BUT THANK
YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION AND
THANK YOU FOR EVERYONE WHO CAME
TODAY
[inaudible]
AB
.
I HAD A
FIFTY I WHILE WE TAKE A
TWENTY MINUTE RECESS.
WE WILL RETURN AT
THREE FIFTY
FIVE WE ARE BACK FROM RECESS AND
MOVING A FILE ITEM SEVEN SB
SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE SENATOR RUBIO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN
[inaudible]
HELLO EVERYONE.
IT'S QUITE THE OR YOU'LL GET TO
APPEAR SO THANK YOU FOR BEING
PATIENT AND WHEN YOU PRESS TO
PRESENT.
SO -- GOOD MORNING WITH THEM AS
I GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
TIMBRE SENDING SB SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE WHICH WOULD ENABLE YOU TO
WATER COMPANIES TO APPLY FOR
CERTAIN GRANTS.
FROM THE STATE BY CONFORMING TO
OUR FEDERAL INCOME TAX LOSS FOR
TAXABLE YEARS BEGINNING ON
JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY NINETEEN I WOULD LIKE TO
FIRST THANK THE CHAIR.
AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH BY OFFICE TODAY WE
WILL BE ACCEPTING ALL OF THE
AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED BY THE
COMMITTEE WHICH INCLUDE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR ME TO
WATER COMPANIES. TO ENSURE
EFFECTIVE TRANSPARENCY AS WELL
AS INCLUDE A FIVE YEAR SUNSET
DATE.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA DOES NOT
RECOGNIZE THE FEDERAL FIVE ONE
C. TWELVE TAX EXEMPT STATUS.
A MAJOR WATER COMPANIES AND
THEREFORE THE RESIDENTS OF ME TO
WATERCOMPANIES ARE IN FACT TAP
TAXED TWICE IF THEY ACCEPT
GRANTS. TO HELP OR CONSOLIDATE
THEIR WATER SYSTEMS THROUGH THE
PASSAGE OF PROPOSITION ONE AND
SIXTY EIGHT THE STATE HOUSE MADE
HUMAN RIGHTS. TO WATER A
PRIORITY THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
MAINTAINS A DATABASE OF SYSTEMS.
SERVING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED HELP.
COMPLY WITH SAFE DRINKING WATER
REGULATIONS TO GRANTS AND A
CONSOLIDATION. 18% OF THOSE
SYSTEMS LISTED ARE SMALL MUTUAL
WATER COMPANIES.
IN THOSE INSTANCES LOGISTIC
PRECLUDES AND ECONOMICAL
PHYSICAL CONNECTION BETWEEN
SYSTEMS OR EVEN A MANAGERIAL
CONSOLIDATION.
THERE ARE OTHER ME TO WATER
COMPANIES OWNED BY CITIES AT
SHARE IN THE COST OF OPERATING
COMMON FACILITIES AND WELLS THUS
REDUCING THE COST FOR TAXPAYERS.
SUCH CITIES ALSO INCLUDE MY
DISTRICT TODAY WITH ME AS A
DONALD BIG EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA WHICH WATER COMPANIES
AND HE'S HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU.
TOàN BURKE -- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE THE CASE FOR SB SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE OH TO THANK SENATOR RUBIO --
FOR OFFERING THIS BILL -- AND
AND THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE A
PATH FOR ALIGNING THE FEDERAL
FIVE OH ONE C. TWELVE TAX EXEMPT
DESIGNATION FOR ME TO WATER
COMPANIES WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TAX CODE.
CUTTING TO THE CHASE YOU KNOW
WHY DO WE NEED THIS BILL NOW --
SB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE IS NEEDED
BECAUSE OF THE GREATER FOCUS BY
THE GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
THIS SESSION AND HELPING SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS.
ARE REACH LEVELS OF WATER SUPPLY
WATER QUALITY RELIABILITY.
AND RESILIENCY ESPECIALLY AFTER
THE LAST FIVE YEAR DROUGHT.
OF AS THE SENATOR MENTIONED OF
OUR THREE HUNDRED MEMBERS IN THE
ASSOCIATION ONLY TWENTY SIX HAVE
MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED
CONNECTIONS -- BY ALIGNING THE
STATE TAX CODE WITH THE FEDERAL
FIVE OH ONE C. TWELVE TAX EXEMPT
DESIGNATION GRANTS WILL BE
DEPLOYED TO HELP AT RISK MUTUAL
WATER COMPANIES AS WELL THIS
FACILITY CONSOLIDATIONS OF
ACUTELY AT RISK.
WATER SYSTEMS IS INTENDED IN
PROP ONE AND PROP SIXTY EIGHT AS
WELL AS AB TWO FORTY SB SIX
SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX AND SB.
SIX OH SIX FURTHER MORE HI
PERFORMING.
PERFORMING BUT VULNERABLE SMALL
WATER MUTUAL WATER COMPANIES
WILL BE A POWER TO MEET STATE
WATER CONSERVATION AND FINANCIAL
RESERVE REQUIREMENTS WITHOUT
BEING SUBJECT TO TAXES FOR THE
INCOME FROM METERED WATER SALES
AND INTEREST EARNED ON THEIR
RESERVE ACCOUNTS.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR YES
VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
WITH THIS BILL COMES UP THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE I'M THE ONLY
COMMITTEE MEMBER HERE SO I HAVE
NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
AS WELL THANK YOU SO ONCE AGAIN
AS A ALREADY SHARED -- THIS IS
AREAS THAT ARE GEOGRAPHICALLY
ISOLATED FROM LARGER ONES AND SO
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL
THING.
AND THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE THIS TESTIMONY
ONLY TODAY BUT YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION Q. AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE -- MOVING A
FILE ITEMS. FIVE SB.
SIX TWENTY SIX CENTER STERN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN YES THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR.
SAYING SIX TWENTY SIX WHICH
REINTRODUCES THE RECENT --
SUNSET BUSINESS TAX CREDIT FOR
ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE MEMBERS WHO
ARE CALLED THE SERVICE IN
DEFENSE THE NATION.
THE SMALL TAX CREDIT APPLIES TO
BUSINESS OWNERS TO MEET THREE
CRITERIA -- YOU'VE GOT A RECEIVE
A PRESIDENTIAL DIRECTIVE TO
DEPLOY FOR ACTIVE COMBAT OR
DEFENSE OWN A SMALL BUSINESS
WHICH IS A BUSINESS BANG INTO
UNDER FIFTY CARE LESS.
AND OPERATE A LOOK AT A LOSS OR
CEASE TO OPERATE.
THESE FEES AS WE KNOW CAN BE
VERY DAMAGING TO SERVICE MEMBER
BUSINESS OWNERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES -- SO THIS WILL
HOPEFULLY PROVIDE THEM SOME
STABILITY WHILE THEY'RE OVERSEE
SERVING A WE KNOW THE FTP
ESTIMATES AN AVERAGE OF FORTY
THOUSAND AND LOSSES TO THESE
BUSINESSES WHEN THEIR OWNERS ARE
DEPLOYED.
IF THEY'RE ABLE TO REMAIN OPEN
AND ALL.
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I
THOUGHT.
WHEN ASSISTANCE?
FOR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GREAT AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
AMENDMENTS TO COMPLY WITH
SECTION FORTY ONE THERE'S NO
QUICK COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE
ANYMORE WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE
RESPECT ESPRESSO THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE THANK YOU FOR
TESTIMONY ONLY BUT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION THANK YOU.
TERRA GALGIANI SECTION.
FILE ITEM SIX SB SEVEN SIXTY
THREE WHICH LIKE TO OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL IS DESIGNED TO
TO HELP VICTIMS OF OUR WILD
FIRES WHO HAVE LOST THEIR HOMES
IN THEIR ENTIRETY OR HAVE LOST
SO MUCH OF THEIR HOME.
THAT THEY ARE UNABLE TO KEEP IT --
SB SEVEN SIXTY THREE PROVIDES
THAT DISCHARGES OF RESIDENTS
INDEBTEDNESS OCCURRING ON OR
AFTER JANUARY FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND
BEFORE JANUARY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND NINE ARE EXCLUDED FROM
AN INDIVIDUAL'S GROSS INCOME.
THE MORTGAGE THAT IS EXCLUDED
ONLY WHEN IT'S DUE THE LOSS OF
RESIDENTS WITHIN A FEDERALLY
DECLARED DISASTER AREAS SUCH AS
THE WILD FIRES THAT WE SAW HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
WHEN A LENDER CANCELS A
BORROWER'S DEBT FEDERAL LAW
TREATS THE AMOUNT OF DEBT
CANCELLED AS TAXABLE INCOME FOR
THE BORROWER?
THIS PUTS VICTIMS OF NATURAL
DISASTERS ON THE HOOK FOR PAYING
LARGE SUMS IN TAXES WHEN THEY'RE
MOST VULNERABLE AND IT'S NOT
ACTUALLY INCOME IT'S PHANTOM
INCOME THAT THEY'RE NEVER GOING
TO SEE.
SB SEVEN SIXTY THREE WOULD
ENSURE THE COUNCIL MORTGAGE
DEBTS FOR RESIDENCES IN A
FEDERALLY DECLARED A DISASTER
AREA WILL NOT BE TAXED AS INCOME
HELPING CALIFORNIANS DURING THE
MOST DIFFICULT TIME OF THEIR
LIVES.
MEMBERS THIS BODY PASSED SIMILAR
LEGISLATION IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN THAT APPLY TO YOU ANYONE
WHO WAS -- DISCHARGING
INDEBTEDNESS TO THEIR HOME
BECAUSE OF A FORECLOSURE SHORT
SALE AND AND THE GOVERNOR VETOED
IT.
THIS BODY ALSO DURING THE
HOUSING FORECLOSURE CRISIS.
DID SIMILAR LEGISLATION BECAUSE
WE SAW SO MANY PEOPLE LOSING
THEIR HOMES AND THEY WERE MAKING
ARRANGEMENTS WITH THE BANKS AND
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AT
THAT TIME WOULD THEN COME IN AND
TAX THEM ON A LOSS OF MONEY THAT
THEY NEVER EVER SAW.
THIS IS LIMITED JUST TO THOSE
WHO ARE WHILE FIRE VICTIMS AND
VICTIMS OF OTHER FEDERALLY
DECLARED DISASTERS.
AND I'M WORKING CURRENTLY WITH
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL TO ENSURE
THAT THE BILL CONFORMS TO
SECTION FORTY ONE OF THE RATHER
TAX CODE.
THANK YOU WIN ASSISTANCE.
FOR WHAT IS THE NUMBER SESSION
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE START BURKE.
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE.
THANK YOU FOR BRAIN ABILITY OF
ANY AND THANK YOU -- FOR GETTING
TO A SECTION FORTY ONE
COMPLAINTS TO HAVE A CLOSING --
I JUST WOULD LIKE TO ADD THAT I
MENTIONED CAUCUS A COUPLE OF
MONTHS AGO THAT WE WOULD
PROBABLY SEE PEOPLE LOSING THEIR
HOMES BECAUSE OF THE RATE OF
INSURANCE GOING UP EXPONENTIALLY.
AND IF YOU HAVE IF YOU'RE USED
TO PAYING A HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH IN OFFICE SAID YOUR
INSURANCE GOES UP TO FIVE
HUNDRED OR SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH YOU ARE NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE THAT PAYMENT ON TOP
OF THE HOUSE PAYMENT.
I PREDICTED THAT WE MIGHT SEE
THIS AND INDEED WE ARE NOW
SEEING THIS THIS PROBLEM OCCURS
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL THAT'S
FOR TESTIMONY ONLY BUT THING FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WHERE TURNED